ma ci cazzate pulisce qua porca ladri la
mia bottiglia [ __ ] [ __ ]
licia mi mandi un qualcuno con una scopa
della tigre gazie benvenuti questo video
sono vari j
oggi siamo sul simulatore di scrivanie
del cazzo ragazzi avete mai visto in
vita vostra una tazza che fa break dance
con un barattolo mi mancava ragazzi tra
il trapianto l'identik hua hin cioè
fatto praticamente quasi tutto tranne
quel non aveva in corsia come faccia
fare tanto perché si faccia spaziali i
denti corsia fatemi capire questa cosa
non mi chiamerà dimenticato delle porte
ai ragazzi la prima cosa da fare se
ovviamente si vuole fare un trapianto di
denti in corsia e staccare la radio
perché alla radio rne stroncato sta
perdendo già del sangue al nostro io che
sto perdendo nel saccaccio scusami zio
sta uccidendo il paziente non ha ancora
iniziato questo è bellissimo devo
prendere qualcosa mi fate prendere
qualcosa lo prendono a pugni finché non
li si staccano i denti ma se sei certo
non sembra troppo diablo non mi
ricordavo che dovevo tagliare la
maschera cioè mi aggiungono del lavoro
in più che cazzo gliela mettono a fare
la mascherina ma porca [ __ ] oggi non
c'è verso di che cazzo ne faccio di sta
roba ragazzi sto gioco sta diventando un
senso nel peggiore di una matita che
fluttua certo a posto se grazie a dio mi
è uscita rocca più inutile che potesse
uscirne per togliere i denti
praticamente ecco forse con questo lo
zio mordi sta roba che arrivò spero si
possa fare con questo perché se no non
so come toglierli denti abbiate pazienza
non ne ho idea
niente non si si si è fatta pregare ce
la sto facendo
3 ok lo spiantato gli ha praticamente
tolto la bocca voleva fare un
propriamente potevo fare ping a
togliergli la faccia si è mangiato un
quantitativo di denti assurdo però va
bene così
adesso mi servirebbe una presina che
ovviamente non prenderò mai perché i
carrelli mi sfuggono di mano
però ciò quest'anno si no e vabbè
scusami ascoltami si sa non è che ti
voglio lanciare addosso europa però non
so dove ma ecco perfetto arrivati a
questo punto
ragazzi si infila per bene questa cosa
nel naso del paziente per controllare
che non ci siano denti rimasti da
qualche parte o poi dopo averla messa
nel natura infiliamo nella bocca perché
bisogna pulire
no io l'obiettivo sarebbe quello di
riprendere i denti con questa cosa qui
piccola ci sono più sporchi di quelli di
prima e li mettiamo al posto di quelli
di prima uno per uno c'è niente dove
cazzo hanno messo in teoria sarebbero da
mettere per tipologia sì ecco perfetto
state per assistere alla dentatura più
bella del secolo siamo partiti benissimo
amico mio avrei un sorriso la hollywood
quando finirò contento perché io gli ho
devi sapere che ho fatto io ho fatto i
denti a michael jackson via paris hilton
li ho fatti a tutti quanti perché sono
un fenomeno me la cavo veramente bene
con i denti zio quindi 66 in buone mani
per ora ci siano perché una matita staff
lui perché io certe cose di questo gioco
non le capisco e non le capirò mai se io
ti metto dei denti nel naso o te li
metto in bocca devi tenerti cioè non
ingoiarli perché sono perfetti capisco
zio che non ci vede più dalla fame però
io vorrei soltanto dirvi ma esiste un
sorriso più bello di questo
non ci sono io veramente sono no no no
no se avesse mai bisogno di un trapianto
di identico cosa così chiamatemi perché
io sono il numero 1 ho vinto per fare è
stato qualcosa di epico comunque
veramente adoro quando succedono le cose
e stata una cosa è adesso mi spieghi che
cazzo perché esse musical al telefono
c'è ma io posso si posso scrivere sulle
sul mio blocco note ma sei serio io la
prima sta cosa epica eccolo ecco cynthia
riecco il mi piazzo le città di segnare
il mi piace quindi ci vuole un mi piace
è d'obbligo
volevo disegnare un pene però non son
riuscito a disegnare un pennino ragazzi
questi sono tutti artisti casa lo slider
man
sull'uscita di se non volevo fare un
pene ma ho disegnato lo slider man
bellissimo da ragazzi basta con liz
lander many mi piace perché troppa arte
in un colpo solo poi fa male l'altra via
in ambulanza
ci possiamo fare questo sì devo arrivare
prima o poi a fare quello nello spazio
coi denti si siamo pronti per questa
altra mentono e io veramente l'ambulanza
veramente c'è fighissima me la ricordo
ma non così bella grazie veramente
gradisce nel succo devo buttare su un po
di roba tra l'altro è caduto
probabilmente un braccio non me lo
ricordavo così incasinato trapianto in
ambulanza ma affanculo
ma la madonna che cazzo sono ultimo temi
andare avanti che sono non lo spacco più
alta lascia disposizio prima che muoia
perché gli cadono delle cose in testa
diano piano scusa giuro non me lo
ricordavo così incasinato in ambulanza
perché fare una mossa ci metto mezz'ora
perché sbanda ogni tre secondi staccato
di ambulanza fatemici friggere solo il
cervello perché almeno sono più contento
eccolo qui per sei più intelligente di
prima non ti lamentare per ce la faccio
no non riesco a prendere starò si ok
mezz'ora per prendere sto schifo alla
ragazza piano all'estintore nuovi prego
l'estintore no toglietemi sta merda da
davanti no no no no no no no no non
spegne e ok dovevo togliere i ragazzi
non mi ricordo più neanche come si fa
cooperazione quindi tramite un pezzo non
si sa mai allora sentite bene mio amico
mio non è che si sveglio pur armene
devono si sarebbe incazzato per il dito
medio quindi non è sveglio sarebbe anche
semplici operazioni viggiù se non ci
fosse sì j a guidare sta cazzo di
ambulanza o trevor kick ass
perché o infilzato un polmone polmoni
volanti prossimamente al cinema miano
non riesco perché c'è un cotton fioc
dentro il paziente se riuscissi a però
non lo vuoi non perché ti prego è
inguardabile sandolo regalo ce n'è
veramente invece come non detto me lo
tengo piano devo togliere il cuore
ragazzi ce l'ho praticamente fatta
dottori e solo il cuore favorendo piano
piano piano non questo mi muore ragazzi
michele mi crepa la siringa dove la
siringa da sin
dov'è il cuore dove cazzo è cuore non
avevo perso ho perso eccolo eccolo la
france si gira a sinistra ce l'ho fatta
io se non mi svoltava l'ambulanza
sinistra avevo perso e sei stata la
vittoria più epica in assoluto disagio
un simulator ennio chiosi ragazzi è
stato è stato veramente figo comunque
ragazzi se perché so fare un altro
episodio taglio a tutto questo
dell'ambulanza città perché voglio
arrivare a fare soltanto il trapianto di
denti e quello di occhi nello spazio
quello sarà epico nel prossimo episodio
faccio direttamente quelli presto non ci
arriviamo più che possono chiudere qui
ragazzi come al solito servito è
piaciuto lasciato commento mi piace
anche a base di facebook e come lei vino
trovata una descrizione certo da
prestiti scrive tecnici vediamolo
prossimo video delle ragazze